The last mental disorder that we will discuss, is one that has affected people
throughout history and is a chronic, severe, and disabling brain disorder. And
that's schizophrenia. People with schizophrenia may hear voices that no one
else hears. They think people are plotting against them to harm them. Or, they
believe people are reading their minds or controlling their thoughts. In order
to be diagnosed with schizophrenia, symptoms must persist for at least one
month. In addition, at least one of the symptoms must be either dilusions,
hallucinations, or disorganized speech. The other symptoms must be grossly
disorganized behavior or catatonic behavior, and negative symptoms. By negative
symptoms we mean for example a person not speaking or being unable to
experience emotion. Let's go back to Susan to look at some of these in more
detail.